I want to tell you about my search for
purpose as a journalist and how Dolly
Parton helped me figure it out so I've
been telling audio stories for about 20
years first on the radio and then in
podcast when I started the radio show
radio lab in 2002 here was the
quintessential story move we would do
we'd bring on somebody it's one of the
most hypnotic and spellbinding
spectacles in nature because you have to
keep in mind it is absolutely silent
like this guy mathematicians chief
Strogatz
and he would paint a picture picture it
there's a riverbank in Thailand in the
remote part of the jungle
you're in a canoe slipping down the
river there's no sound of anything maybe
the occasional you know exotic jungle
bird or something so you're in this
imaginary canoe with Steve and in the
air all around you are millions of
fireflies and what you see is sort of a
randomized starry night effect because
all the fireflies are blinking at
different rates which is why you to
expect but according to Steve in this
one place for reasons no scientists can
fully explain
with thousands of lights on and then off
all in sync
[Music]
now it's around this time that I would
generally bring in the beautiful music
as I just did and you'd start to get
that warm feeling a feeling that we know
from science kind of localizes in your
head and chest and spreads through your
body it's that feeling of wonder from
2002 to 2010 I did hundreds of these
stories science II neuroscience II very
heady brainy stories that would always
resolve into that feeling of wonder and
I began to see that as my job to lead
people to moments of wonder what that
sounded like was oh wow wow that's
amazing
whoa but I began to get kind of tired of
these stories I mean partially was the
repetition I remember there was a day I
was sitting at the computer making the
sound of a neuron you know take some
white noise chop it up very easy sound
to make I remembered to thinking I have
made this sound 25 times but it was more
than that it was there was a familiar
path to these stories you walk the path
of truth which is made of science and
you get to wonder now I love science
don't get me wrong my parents emigrated
from a war-torn country came to America
and science for them was like more their
identity than anything else and I
inherited that from them but there was
something about that simple movement
from science to wonders that just
started to feel wrong to me like is that
the only path the story can take around
2012 I ran into a bunch of different
stories that made me think
no one story in particular where we
interviewed a guy who described chemical
weapons being used against him and his
fellow villagers in the mountains of
Laos Western scientists went there
measured for chemical weapons didn't
find any we interviewed the man about
this he said the scientists were wrong
we said but they tested he said I don't
care I know what happened to me and we
went back and forth and back and forth
and make a long story short the
interview ended in tears
I felt felt horrible like hammering at a
scientific truth when someone has
suffered that wasn't gonna heal anything
and maybe I was relying too much on
science to find the truth and it really
did feel at that moment that there are a
lot of truths in the room and we were
only looking at one of them so I thought
I gotta get better at this
so for the next eight years I committed
myself to doing stories where you heard
truths collide we did stories about the
politics of consume you heard the
perspective of survivors and
perpetrators whose narratives clients
stories about rape black men are
systematically eliminated from juries
and yet the rules that try and prevent
that from happening only make things
worse
stories about counterterrorism wanton mo
detainees stories where everything is
disputed all you can do is struggle to
try and make sense and the struggle kind
of became the point I began to think
maybe that's my job to lead people to
moments of struggle here's what that
sounded like but I see I like oh I know
well so like that I mean I you know I
that's I right there I wanted to hear
that sound in every single story because
that sound is kind of our current moment
right we live in a world where truth is
no longer just a set of facts to be
captured it's become a process it's gone
from being a noun to being a verb but
how do you end that story like what
literally kept happening is we'd be you
know telling the story cruising along
two viewpoints and conflict you get to
the end and it's just like no let me see
you at the end what how do you end that
story you can't just like
happily-ever-after it cuz that doesn't
feel real the same time if you just
leave people in that stuck place like
why did I just listen to that like it
felt like there had to be another move
there had to be a way beyond the
struggle and this is what brings me to
Dali or st. Dali is we like to call her
in the South I want to tell you about
one little
Limor of an epiphany that I had during a
nine part series called Dolly Parton's
America last year it was a bit of a
departure for me but I just had this
intuition that dolly could help me
figure out this ending problem and here
was the basic intuition you go to a
dolly concert you see men and trucker
hats standing next to men and drag
Democrats standing next to Republic
women holding hands every different kind
of person smashed together all of these
people that we are told should hate each
other are there singing together she
somehow carved out this unique space in
American I wanted to know how did she do
that so I interviewed dolly twelve times
two separate continents she started
every interview this way ask me whatever
you ask me I will tell you what I
watching here she is undeniably a force
of nature but the problem that I ran
into is that I had chosen a conceit for
this series that my soul had had trouble
with dolly sings a lot about the south
if you go through her discography you
will hear song after song about
Tennessee
[Music]
tennessee tennessee mountain home
tennessee mountain memories now I grew
up in Tennessee and I felt no nostalgia
for that place I was the scrawny Arab
kid who came from the place that
invented suicide bombing I I spent a lot
of time in my room when I left Nashville
I left I remember being at Dollywood
standing in front of a replica replica
of her tennessee mountain home people
all around me were crying this is a this
is a set why are you crying I couldn't
understand why they were so emotional
especially given my relationship to the
south and I started to honestly have
panic attacks about am I not the right
person for this project but then twist
of fate we meet this guy Brian Seaver
Dolly's nephew and bodyguard and on a
whim he drives producer Shima only I and
I out of Dollywood around the backside
of the mountains up the mountains 20
minutes down a narrow dirt road through
giant wooden gates that look right out
of Game of Thrones and into the actual
Tennessee mountain home but the real
place thou have the real Tennessee
mountain oh and I'm gonna score this
part with vogner because you understand
in Tennessee lore this is like hallowed
ground with a tennessee mountain home so
i remember standing there on the grass
next to the pigeon river butterflies
doing loop-de-loops in the air and I had
my own moment of wonder
Dali's Tennessee mountain home looks
exactly like my dad's home in the
mountains of Lebanon her house looks
just like the place that he left that
simple bit of layering led me to have a
conversation with him that I'd never had
before but the pain he felt leaving his
home and how he hears that in Dolly's
music then I had a conversation with
Dolly where she described her songs as
migration music even that classic song
Tennessee mountain home if you listen to
it
front porch on a summer afternoon in a
straight back chair on two legs leaned
against the wall
[Music]
it's about trying to capture a moment
that you know is already gone but if you
can paint it vividly
maybe you can freeze it in place almost
like in resin trapped between past and
present that is the immigrant experience
and that simple thought led me to a
million conversations started talking to
musicologist about country music as a
whole this genre that I've always felt
so having nothing to do with where I
came from is actually made up of
instruments and musical styles that came
directly from the Middle East in fact
there were trade routes that ran from
what is now Lebanon right up into the
mountains of East Tennessee I can
honestly say standing there looking at
her home was the first time I felt like
I'm at Tennessee in that is honestly
true and this wasn't a one-time thing I
mean over and over again she would force
me beyond the simple categories I had
constructed for the world I remember
talking with her about her seven-year
partnership with Porter Wagoner 1967 she
joins this band he is the biggest thing
in country music she is a backup singer
and nobody within a short time she gets
huge he gets too jealous he then Sue's
her for three million dollars when she
tries to leave now it would be really
easy to see Porter Wagoner as like a
tight classic patriarchal jackass trying
to hold her back
but anytime I would suggest that to her
like come on this is a guy I mean you
see it in the videos too he's got his
arm around you it there's a there's a
power thing happening for sure well it's
more complicated from that it's just I
mean just think about it he had had this
show for years he had he didn't need me
to have his hit show he wasn't expecting
me to be all that I was either I was a
serious entertainer he didn't know that
I mean he he didn't know how many dreams
I had in fact she kept telling me don't
bring you a stupid way of seeing the
world under my story cuz that's not what
it was yeah there was power but that's
not all there was
you can't summarize this alright just to
zoom out what do I make of this well I
think there's something in a year that
Clou a way forward as journalists we
love difference we love to fetishize
difference but increasingly in this
confusing world we need to be the bridge
between those differences but how do you
do that
I think for me now the answer is simple
you interrogate those differences you
hold them for as long as you can until
like up on that mountain something
happens something reveals itself story
cannot end indifference it's got to end
in Revelation I'm coming back from that
trip on the mountain friend of mine gave
me a book that gave this whole idea a
name in psychotherapy there's this idea
called the third which essentially goes
like this typically we think of
ourselves as these autonomous units I do
something to you
you do something to me but according to
this theory when two people come
together and really commit to seeing
each other in that mutual act of
recognition they actually make something
new a new entity that is their
relationship you can think of Dolly's
concerts as sort of a cultural third
space the way she sees all the different
parts of her audience the way they see
her creates the spiritual architecture
of that space and I think now that is my
calling it as a journalist as a
storyteller that's just an American
living in a country struggling to hold
every story I tell has got to find the
third that place where the things we
hold is different resolve themselves
into something new
thank you
[Music]